Como en el último video, quiero hacer un
par de ejemplos de calentamiento
antes de hacer un problema de aplicación,
en este caso las ecuaciones son un poco más simples
aunque vamos a seguir los mismos pasos para
desarrollarlas o más bien diríamos,
vamos a seguir pasos matemáticamente
legítimos para llegar a una solución válida.
Aquí tenemos, 3 por "x" menos 1
es igual a 2 por "x" más 3,
veamos qué podemos hacer aquí.
Lo primero que me gustaría hacer y no hay una única manera de hacer esto,
pero lo que yo voy a hacer para empezar
es distribuir el 3 aquí y el 2 acá,
así que 3 por "x" menos 1
es igual a "3x" menos 3,
tan solo he distribuido el 3 y esto es igual
distribuyendo el 2, a "2x" más 2 por 3 igual a 6.
Y ahora lo que voy a hacer es, agrupar las
constantes de un lado de la ecuación
y agrupar as variables del otro lado de la ecuación,
así es que vamos a deshacernos de este "2x"
que está en el lado derecho de la ecuación.
Para esto voy a restar "2x" al lado derecho
y voy a usar una notación ligeramente distinta
a la que he usado en los videos anteriores y esto lo hago así pues tú te puedes topar con distintas notaciones.
Así es que voy a restar "2x"
de este lado de la ecuación,
pero si resto "2x"
también tengo que restar "2x"
de este otro lado de la ecuación.
¿Y cuando hago esto qué obtengo?
Del lado izquierdo obtenemos,
"3x" menos "2x" nos da "x",
simplemente "x" menos 3,
"x" menos 3 del lado izquierdo
y del lado derecho estos "2x" y "-2x" se cancelan,
era lo que queríamos,
así es que nos queda tan solo 6.
"x" menos 3 es igual a 6, logramos eliminar
el "2x" del lado derecho al restar "2x"
a ambos lados de la ecuación.
Bien, ahora vamos a deshacernos
de este -3 del lado izquierdo,
para eso vamos a sumar 3
a ambos lados de la ecuación,
sumamos 3 del lado izquierdo
y sumamos 3 del lado derecho,
esto lo podemos ver como si
estuviéramos sumando a la ecuación original,
la ecuación 3 igual a 3 que es una identidad,
como la ecuación "-2x" igual a "-2x",
son al final de cuentas distintas maneras
de ver el mismo proceso,
¿y qué nos resulta?
Ahora el lado izquierdo simplemente nos queda
"x", se cancelan -3 y 3, nos queda simplemente "x"
y del lado derecho nos queda 6 más 3
es igual a 9 y ya hemos concluido,
ya tenemos la solución de la ecuación.
A ver, comprobemos la solución.
3 por 9 menos 1 esto es 3 por 8
y esto es lo mismo que 24.
Checamos ahora el lado derecho,
tenemos que es 2 por 9 más 3, 9 más 3 es 12,
2 por 12 es igual 24, 24 es igual a 24
y hemos comprobado la solución "x" igual a 9.
Siguiente problema, "z" sobre 16 es igual
a 2 por "3z" más 1 y todo eso dividido entre 9,
parece un problema peliagudo pero empecemos
multiplicando ambos lados de la ecuación por 9,
entonces multiplicando por 9 el lado
izquierdo y multiplicando por 9 el lado derecho,
¿qué tenemos?
del lado izquierdo es 9 sobre "16z"
y esto es igual, estos 9 se cancelan
y me queda tan solo 2 por "3z" más 1,
vamos a realizar el producto del lado derecho,
así es que el lado izquierdo nos queda 9/16z
y entonces distribuyendo el 2,  sería 2 por "3z"
es igual a "6z" más 2 por 1 que es igual a 2.
Voy ahora a pasar todos los "z" del lado izquierdo,
para eso voy a restar "6z"
del lado izquierdo y del lado derecho,
voy a restar "6z" del lado izquierdo
y esto es igual a "-6z" del lado derecho,
¿qué tenemos?
Del lado izquierdo sería,
9 sobre "16z" menos "6z",
9 sobre 16 menos 6,
¿cuánto es 6 en dieciseisavos?
A ver, hagámoslo por acá.
¿6 es igual a qué dividido entre 16?
6 por 10 = 60,
6 por 6 = 36, esto es 96,
96 sobre 16,
así es que es -96 sobre 16,
todo eso multiplicado por "z",
este -6 lo transformé en -96/16
y de lado derecho nos resulta,
"6z" menos "6z" se cancelan,
era lo que queríamos hacer
y nos queda tan solo 2.
¿Y esto de aquí a qué es igual?
Lo voy a hacer en naranja, a ver tenemos,
9/16 menos 96/16,
la diferencia entre 96 y 9 es 87
y por supuesto como el mayor es negativo, esto sería -87, así es que esto es "-87/16z" y esto es igual a 2.
Y y a casi terminamos, tan solo tenemos que
multiplicar ambos lados de la ecuación
por el recíproco de este coeficiente.
Así es que multiplicamos
ambos lados de la ecuación por 16 -16/87,
también del lado derecho -16/87
y del lado izquierdo se cancelan estos términos
87 con 87, 16 y 16, menos por menos me da más
me queda "z" del lado izquierdo
y del lado derecho me quedan 2 por -16 es -32/87.
Y ya hemos terminado,
no es una respuesta muy bonita que digamos,
pero como hemos dicho siempre,
hay muchísimos caminos para llegar a la respuesta
quizá hubieras podido multiplicar
la ecuación primero por 16
o a lo mejor primero
haber distribuido el 2,
de cualquier manera
si haces bien las cosas,
debes de llegar a la misma respuesta
que nosotros hemos obtenido,
bien, ahora hagamos un problema de aplicación,
ya que hemos hecho nuestro calentamiento.
Muy bien, dice, Manuel y Tamara están discutiendo
acerca de un truco de números que oyeron.
Tamara le pide a Andrés que piense un número,
supongamos que "x" es el número que piensa Andrés,
le dice que piense un número,
lo multiplique por 5,
así es que esto es lo que le está pidiendo Tamara, Tamara le está pidiendo a Andrés que piense un número,
lo multiplique por 5, déjame irlo haciendo,
multiplique por 5,
así es que lo multiplica por 5 y resta 3 del resultado...
y reste...
déjame hacerlo con un color distinto,
lo voy a hacer en azul...
y reste 3 del resultado,
así es que reste 3 del resultado.
Entonces es el turno de Manuel,
aquí está Manuel, así es que Manuel aparece
y le pide a Andrés que piense un número,
le va a mostrar el truco de números
por lo cual él también le pide a Andrés
que piense un número,
vamos a llamarle "x",
súmale 5, le pide que le sume 5,
le suma 5 y multiplica el resultado...
y multiplica el resultado por 3...
multiplica el resultado por 3...
Andrés dice que
no importa la manera como haga el truco,
siempre obtiene la misma respuesta,
¿cuál es el número de Andrés?
Sin importar si primero multiplica el número
por 5 y luego le resta 3
ó primero le suma al número 5
y luego lo multiplica por 3,
siempre obtiene el mismo número
y eso significa que estos 2 son iguales,
obtiene la misma respuesta,
significa que estos dos números son iguales.
Resolvamos entonces esta ecuación.
Tenemos que "5x" menos 3 es igual a "3x" más 5,
esa es nuestra ecuación.
Como primer paso voy a distribuir este 3,
entonces esto es igual a 3 por "x"
más 3 por 5 = 15, no se te olvide que hay que multiplicar
todos los términos dentro del paréntesis
por el 3, éste es 15,
muy bien.
Y del lado izquierdo por supuesto es "5x" menos 3
y ahora, creo que ya sabes cómo me gusta operar,
voy a llevar todos los términos en "x" a un solo lado,
los voy a llevar al lado izquierdo,
para eso voy a restar "-3x"
a ambos lados de la ecuación,
restamos "-3x" del lado izquierdo
y restamos "-3x" del lado derecho,
¿del lado izquierdo que tenemos?
Tenemos "5x" menos "3x"
es "2x" menos 3,
del lado derecho "3x" y "-3x" se cancelan
y solo nos queda 15, esto es igual a 15.
Ahora voy a pasar todos los coeficientes
al lado derecho,
voy a cancelar este -3 para lo cual
voy a sumar 3 a ambos lados de la ecuación,
sumo 3 del lado izquierdo y sumo 3 del lado derecho, ¿qué nos da ahora?
Del lado izquierdo nos queda
"2x" menos 3 y 3 se cancelan
y del lado derecho va a ser 15 más 3 = 18.
Despejamos "x" dividiendo entre 2 ambos lados,
2 entre 2 es igual a 1,
así es que "x" es igual a 18 entre 2,
"x" es igual a 9.
En ambos casos,
Andrés estaba pensando en el número 9,
veamos si esto funciona para el método de ambos,
el de Tamara y el de Manuel.
Si tengo 5 por...
hagamos este 9, 5 por 9,
5 por 9 = 45 menos 3, 45 menos 3 es 42,
ese según el método de Tamara,
ahora según el método de Manuel
si tengo 9 más 5 es 14,
así es que esto es 3 por 14 y 3 por 14
es 3 por 10 = 30, 3 por 4 = 12,
esto es igual a 42,
así es que Andrés tenía razón,
eligió al azar el número 9
y sin importar el método que siguió,
obtuvo el mismo número 42.